>> IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO DO THE KINDS OF
THINGS THEY WANT TO DO, THEY
WANT FREEDOM TO DO THAT.
BUT IT COMES A TIME WHEN YOU ARE
DEALING WITH A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS THAT COULD INVOLVE YOU,
YOUR FAMILY, AND EVERYONE ELSE
THAT SOMETHING SUPERSEDES THAT
NEEDED TO DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO.
>> Laura: DR. FAUCI ISN'T
TALKING ABOUT OBAMA'S BIG
BIRTHDAY BLOW OUT FILLED WITH
ALL THE CELEBS AND DUBIOUS
DANCING TECHNIQUES, THAT PARTY
WAS HELD WITHOUT MASKS AND
INSIDE A TENT, WAS HE MOUTHING
OFF ABOUT THAT?
HE'S TALKING ABOUT STURGIS, AN
OUTDOOR MOTORCYCLE RALLY IN
SOUTH DAKOTA.
I HAD A DATA VIEW, THE SAME
THING HAPPENED LAST YEAR'S
EVENT, THE ONE THE MEDIA ALSO
FREAKED OUT OVER CALLING IT A
SUPER-SPREADER.
IT TURNS OUT TO THOSE CONCERNS
WERE BOGUS.
OUT OF 460,000 ATTENDEES, THERE
WAS JUST 0.1% POSITIVE COVID
CASES.
THAT DOESN'T STOP MSNBC PANIC
PUSHER JOY REID.
>> AT EVENT LIKE THE STURGIS
MOTORCYCLE RALLY, BECOME A
SUPER-SPREADER IN THE MAKING
WITH ITS 700,000 ATTENDEES
CERTAIN TO SPREAD COVID ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
REPUBLICANS ARE STILL SCREAMING
"FREEDOM" IT'S ABOUT LIFE AND
DEATH.
REPUBLICANS NO WHAT SIDE TO BE
ON AND IT SEEMS THEY HAVE CHOSEN
TO BE ON THE SIDE OF DEATH.
>> Laura: COMING FROM A PARTY
THAT EMBRACES ABORTION ON
DEMAND.
GOVERNOR KRISTI NOEM, DO YOU
CARE TO WEIGH IN ON BEING ON THE
SIDE OF DEATH THIS WEEKEND AT
STURGIS?
>> YOU JUST MADE AN EXCELLENT
POINT, I THINK IT'S INTERESTING
THAT BESIDES THE POLITICAL
PARTY, THE DEMOCRATS WHO EMBRACE
GETTING ABORTION ON DEMAND ARE
ACCUSING US OF EMBRACING DEATH
WHEN WE ARE JUST ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO MAKE PERSONAL CHOICES AND
HAVE PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY
OVER WHEN THEY WANT TO ASSEMBLE,
ONE THEY WANT TO GATHER AND
SPEND TIME OUTDOORS, ENJOYING
THEIR WAY OF LIFE.
WE'VE HAD A FANTASTIC EVENT IN
SOUTH DAKOTA, THE RALLY WILL END
SUNDAY, I GUESS, AND THEY ARE
HAVING A FANTASTIC TIME.
WE ARE GLAD EVERYBODY MADE THE
TRIP TO SOUTH DAKOTA.
>> Laura: WE CHECKED
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WEBSITE
BEFORE WE WENT ON AIR TONIGHT
AND I THINK THE SEVEN DAY
AVERAGE OF COVID DEATHS IS ABOUT
0.1% IN SOUTH DAKOTA, YOU HAVE
AMONG THE BEST RESULTS NOW GIVEN
THE FACT THAT YOU DIDN'T LOCK
DOWN, YOU DIDN'T MASK MANDATE,
AND IT SEEMS LIKE YOU HAVE AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF CIRCULATING
IMMUNITY, NATURAL IMMUNITY FROM
PRIOR EXPOSURES.
DOES THAT TRACK WITH WHAT YOU
ARE SEEING?
>> YES, IT DOES.
WE HAVE THAT GOING ON, OVER 50%
OF OUR POPULATION IS VACCINATED
AND THE FOLKS THAT ARE VISITING
SOUTH DAKOTA, WE NEED TO REMIND
THEM PEOPLE CAME LAST YEAR OUT
OF 460,000 VISITORS WE HAD LAST
YEAR TO THE RALLY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH TRACKED
FOR MANY WEEKS AFTER THAT AND
ALL WE WERE ABLE TO VERIFY WERE
125 CASES.
MEDICAL HELP AVAILABLE, PEOPLE
WILL LIKE IT, WE ARE CONDUCTING
THIS IN A WAY THAT CERTAINLY
PROTECTS PEOPLE'S FREEDOMS.
WHAT DR. FAUCI IS DOING BUT I
CONSTANTLY TARGETING THE STURGIS
BIKE RALLY AND FOCUSING ON
SOUTH DAKOTA AND IGNORING
LIBERALS WHO GATHER EVERY SINGLE
DAY IN HER HYPOCRISY IS JUST
WRONG.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE HE IS BUILDING
DISTRUST INTO HIS PROFESSION.
WE NEED OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS, WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TRUST THEM AND HE HAS GOTTEN
POLITICAL AND PICKED WINNERS AND
LOSERS BASED ON WHO HE LIKES.
>> Laura: I DON'T THINK HE
FREAKED OUT ABOUT LOLLAPALOOZA,
THEY HAD VACCINE REQUIREMENTS
FOR ATTENDEES, AND THEY HAD VERY
FEW INFECTIONS AS WELL.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING WE JUST MENTIONED.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
CLEARLY FLOATING TO SEE THE
REACTION.
A POTENTIAL FEDERAL MOVE TO
PREVENT INTERSTATE TRAVEL AMONG
THOSE WHO ARE NOT FULLY
VACCINATED, THEREBY ISOLATING
PEOPLE ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS A
SERIOUS CONSIDERATION BUT IT'S
OBVIOUSLY IN THE MINDS OF SOME
OF THESE ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS GIVEN WHAT THEY ARE
SEEING IN SOME PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> I WOULDN'T DOUBT IT IF THEY
WERE CONSIDERING IT, WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN DIFFERENT
DIRECTIVES COME DOWN FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO OUR STATE.
FEDERAL GOVERNORS ARE COMPLYING
WITH AND MANY LIKE ME ARE NOT.
WHEN THIS FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION, WHEN THIS
WHITE HOUSE, WHEN JOE BIDEN
OVERSTEPPED HIS CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY AND TAKES AWAY
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS TO MAKE
DECISIONS IF THEY ARE SUPPOSED
TO MAKE FOR THEMSELVES, WE WILL
STAND UP.
GOVERNORS MANY TIMES OF THE LAST
LINE OF DEFENSE TO HELP PROTECT
THESE FREEDOMS THAT AMERICANS
HAVE ENJOYED AND REMEMBER, IF
THEY COME FORWARD WITH A
DIRECTIVE LIKE THAT, WE'VE NEVER
SEEN THAT IN THIS COUNTRY
BEFORE.
IT'S UNPRECEDENTED AND IT IS
EXACTLY THE OPPORTUNITY THAT WE
ALL NEED TO STAND UP AND REMIND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF WHAT
THEIR JOB IS, WHAT THEIR JOB
ISN'T AND REMEMBER, WE CANNOT
HAVE LEADERS OVERSTEPPED THEIR
AUTHORITY, ESPECIALLY IN A TIME
OF CRISIS.
>> Laura: ONE MORE THING, THE
MIGRANTS WHO HAVE COME INTO THE
COUNTRY, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS,
1.4 MILLION HAVE BEEN
"ENCOUNTERED" WHATEVER THAT
MEANS ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
ARE YOU ALERTED TO THE DEPOSITS
OF MIGRANTS INTO YOUR STATE WHEN
THEY ARRIVE?
ARE YOU EVER TOLD?
>> I HAVE MY NATIONAL GUARD TO
TOWN THERE ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, I HAVE CLOSE TO 50
MEMBERS DOWN THERE.
>> Laura: RIGHT, THEY'RE STILL
COMING TO YOUR STATE.
>> NO THEY'RE NOT.
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF BECAUSE I
COMMUNICATED WITH ALL OF THOSE
NONPROFITS IN OUR STATE THAT
WOULD ACCEPT THOSE TYPES OF
INDIVIDUALS AND I TOLD THEM,
THEY ALL NEED TO BE LICENSED,
THEY NEED TO BE LICENSED TO BE
IN THE STATE OF SOUTH DAKOTA AND
IF THEY WANT TO CONTINUE TO BE
LICENSED AND TO DO WORK IN OUR
STATE, WHICH WE WANT THEM, WE
WELCOME THEM, WE HAVE GREAT
PARTNERSHIPS, THIS IS SOMETHING
WE WILL BE WATCHING AND
EVALUATING WHAT THEY DO TO BREAK
FEDERAL LAW AND TO VIOLATE THE
TRUST OF THE STATE OF
SOUTH DAKOTA.
>> Laura: DOES THAT INCLUDE
CATHOLIC CHARITIES?
>> IT DOES.
>> Laura: THEY HAVE BEEN
FUNNELING MIGRANTS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
>> I WAS DOWN THERE AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHO IS FUNNELING THEM
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
OUR NATIONAL GUARD ORIGINALLY
WAS OBSERVING AND SPOTTING THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND TURNING THEM
OVER TO BORDER PATROL WHO THEN
WAS DIRECTED TO IMMEDIATELY TURN
THEM OVER TO NONPROFITS AND PUT
THEM ON PLANES AND BUSES AND
DISTRIBUTE THEM.
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN
SOUTH DAKOTA I THINK IS
STRATEGIC, WE'VE GOT OUR GUYS
DOWN THERE, OUR SOLDIERS ARE
DOWN THERE TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
STOPPING THE DRUGS IN THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THAT'S COMING AND
GETTING INDIVIDUALS BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE WE ARE COMMUNICATING
WITH THOSE NONPROFITS.
>> Laura: THEY CARE SO MUCH
ABOUT COVERT BUT THEY ARE
WALTZING THEM RIGHT IN WITH
COVID.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, THAT IS
FASCINATING INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW YOU ARE TRYING TO STOP THE
INFLUX OF MIGRANTS INTO YOUR
STATE.
WE HOPE EVERYONE HAS A GREAT
TI